my audience asked me questions for 10
hours and here are the best moments
let's say my only goal was just to get
rich a what is Rich AF just so we Define
it 100 million why not it's a good
number cool you're willing to work hard
but you have limited skills and
experience what business would you start
like right now 2023 and I have no money
right I would probably build a boring
business in services and I would
probably pick something around the body
you know if I wouldn't just start a
design firm cuz I think that has a high
likelihood of getting disrupted or you
know in some way by AI if I were you
know it's as silly as it sounds like a
nail salon or a lawn care service things
that I mean especially body ones uh
dentist stuff like you still have to go
in and get your teeth taken care of and
many times people value the human
exchange more than something robotic so
for example in the fitness world like
this is my like my data point around
this uh there was a a brand called cocoa
fit and um they struggled a ton and then
eventually went out of business because
they tried to automate personal training
so they created these all-in-one
machines that would you'd have a key fob
and it would count your reps and every
time you went to the machine it would
say how to do more and what what you did
last time it's really cool concept the
problem was their theory was that the
reason that people weren't getting
results is that they didn't know it to
do when the reality is that no one was
showing for the gym people hire personal
trainers because they want another human
to talk to and to hold them accountable
to showing up same reason like if you
had a robot cutting hair there might be
a percentage of the population that do
it but a lot of women like the going to
the hair salon and having that exchange
and so I would probably build a business
around services in general um would be
my way and then I would continue to
scale that and you could do that at a
local chain level and you can make a lot
of money doing that or you could do it
at a national level which would be like
Professional Services I love the idea
behind the c stuff that's going to be
here forever you know let's say
hypothetically the great fires of Las
Vegas burn everything to the ground okay
you lost everything you had to start
again what would you say is the number
one thing that you would have done
differently to get to where you on now
and I have no reputation right no no
reputation yeah it burns my reputation
on the ground with it so I actually have
lost everything before uh and so I I
know what I did and I probably would
have done the same thing so the the the
easiest way that I did to like go make a
100 Grand in a month when I had nothing
uh was that I would go find a business
that was local that I understood and
that I could sell something expensive
for I would front the capital to Market
I would work the leads and I would sit
at the front desk and sell and I would
negotiate what they would be willing to
do a big bulk of services at scale for
so for example if I wanted to find a
chiropractor and I'd say hey I if I sent
you 100 customers this month what's the
lowest rate you would do all 100
customers for this level of service and
then I would just negotiate that down
and then I would spend as much as I
could and sell it for as much as I can
so I can make the spread and then they
would service the customers and for them
it's a zero risk offer CU they don't
have to do anything I front everything
else and then for me I don't have to do
anything but Market and sell and I can
take all of that and so like when I lost
everything I immediately was able to
make 100 Grand the next month by doing
that playbook in your opinion what are
the three most powerful skills that
someone should develop if they want to
make a lot of money I mean the Three
core skills are you got to learn how to
build you got to learn how to sell and
you got to learn how to lead just like
that there we go like in in terms of
maybe like hard skills that someone
should really focus on learning to
develop that like sales copyrighting
leadership what would you say the most
important well those are the three big
buckets
right so it's like one is that like
leadership is just the internal bucket
of getting people to do what you want
them to do at scale right and then from
a selling perspective I include that in
all things that are marketing letting
people know about your stuff promotion
uh and actually converting people into
customers and then the third piece of
Building Product and services is so that
at scale If the product is good enough
then you won't lose customers and if
it's exceptional the product itself will
get you more customers and so most
businesses takeen to their natural
extreme on a promot tional level
typically are leaky buckets because the
product actually sucks and most
businesses suck in general because most
products aren't good and most people
want to cancel very quickly and don't
want to continue to use them which is
why very very good companies are very
rare uh most of them generally are
mediocre or not good and so I prefer to
solve a business from Back to Front
which is like can we find something that
people actually like and want to
continue to use and continue to pay for
and then the marketing is almost a
commoditized skill like it's very easy
to let other people know about your
stuff and do so louder and louder and
louder provided the product is good and
then the internal has to get run with a
leader that can attract the talent to
continue to do this because quickly the
the business will bottleneck based on
the founder and their expertise or
usually they have a niche they might be
product people they might be tech people
they might be Finance people they might
be whatever um and then they have to be
of the character to attract the talent
that will allow them to get to you know
nine figures or whatever it is that
their the goal is you mentioned on a
recent podcast with Tom Bilu uh that you
don't have rules so yeah I for example
you know I quite often end up working up
until midnight 2 am 3: a.m. and
basically [__] up my sleep schedule
because I have too much Freedom right
because I'm self-employed so how do you
kind of strike that balance between
freedom and discipline you know if
you're driven and you want to accomplish
big things it's it's it's kind of 8020
like if you know that when you stay up
late like there are times when I will
gas it and go past my red line in terms
of work and I know that I'm eating into
tomorrow but if I'm like in a flow and
I'm crushing it and the Muse shows up
and the Muse wants to work then I work
you know what I mean but if there's some
days on the flip side where I wake up
and I just feel foggy as [__] and I just
like for whatever reason I ate too much
Mexican last night and my you know I I
just I don't have it that day then I I
might call it earlier like the idea of
me pushing through and punishing when it
comes to the type of work I do if I were
doing a more uh Brute Force work then I
would care less you know what I mean if
it was just like if I was just doing
reach outs I was doing cold calls I was
training personal training sessions I
was cutting hair I'm just I'm just going
to brute force my way through it because
I don't need to have higher brain
function and that's not an insult I'm
just saying like you're not like
thinking of creative things you know
what I mean you're just you're working
the work um but when it comes to like
writing or or making presentations or
communication of some sort it's more I
try and optimize around how can I
maximize over a week how much Flow State
I can be in so I can just get the most
total quality output so it's not about
rules it's more like which of these
things has the highest likel of getting
me the most what's up Kristoff in one
podcast you said that your most feared
decision in life was to quit your job
when you were 22 or 23 my question is
what advice would you give to your
younger self if you could in that exact
situation when you have nothing to lose
it also makes it the best time to make
highrisk decisions because you have a
disproportionate upside not quitting if
you want to do something else like if
you have this desire to do something
else is like not taking a stranger up on
a free lottery ticket on the street if
they give you a free lottery ticket and
you lose you're back to not having
anything if you win then your life
changes forever and so I think a lot of
people place a disproportionate amount
of weight on the opinions of other
people who are going to judge them in
the short term because quitting your job
is short-term pain for long-term
fulfillment if that's what if that's
what you want to pursue because the
short-term pain comes from the Judgment
of s and likely a back you know back
step in income but long term you're
working on the thing that you want to be
working on now if you like your job and
you know what I mean that that probably
doesn't apply to those people but like
if you're in that situation it's really
a long-term short-term sacrifice which a
lot of people aren't able to make the
second question let's think that my
audience uh don't know anything about
Laya except that she's your partner okay
but I think she's she has exceptional
knowledge and she she's a really good
personality if you could only tell one
story about her that makes a complete
picture about her what would it what
would it be so Lila had quit her job to
join me to start gym launch this is when
we were doing turnarounds so we're
flying around the country so she quit
her job after knowing me for only a
month and then started basically living
with me in motel rooms she had built up
a book of business so she was actually
giving up something that she had spent 2
years building to pursue this thing with
me and we were new like we had just
started dating about 6 months into that
I told her that I needed a break and the
she actually asked me she was like it's
sounds like you don't really want me to
be here do you want me to leave and I
was like yes that would be great I had
just lost all the money from the partner
I had this location that I had to either
shut shut down and had no cash to do it
and I had to service all these contracts
that didn't have the money to service
and I also had like three other
businesses that I was trying to run at
the same time I had a caropractor agency
I had my gyms I had Jim launch the
turnaround business I had a dental
agency all of those with different
partners and I was the one who did
Marketing sales for all of it and so I
was just so spread thin and so she I
needed to generate money uh to basically
pay the bills of the gym that I couldn't
pay that the money had just gone out the
door for right after me saying I don't
think we should be together she had to
leave like the next day to go to Hawaii
to launch a gym for this guy that she's
no longer dating that she quit
everything to leave tough situation that
nine out of 10 not even n 99 out of 100
girls would have just said no they would
have been like I'm just going to go back
home and you know try and get all my
clients back but she didn't do that so
she flew out to Hawaii I didn't have
enough money to give her like a nice
place and so so um I had her split in
Airbnb with Five Guys Five dudes and
Lila not ideal and so she worked out of
the Airbnb and well realistic she worked
out of the gym most of the time and did
the biggest launch that we'd ever done
and so like when my world was Crum
crumbling around me and I really needed
her to come through she stood tall and
she did it in a time that I probably
didn't deserve that level of loyalty cuz
I hadn't shown her any and so she did
that and then I made enough money from
her launching that gym that I could pay
off all the bills of the gym that I was
going under that I just lost all the
money on uh to basically come out
breaking even um so that we could
actually go back all in on gym launch
and get rid of the other companies wow
man I think I haven't heard this story
before what what went through through
your mind I I can't really believe this
and understand it well when she did that
I wanted to be with her she had extended
me loyalty that I had not given her
there was probably a few defining
moments in our relationship that was the
first big one thank you very much for
sharing this the next one is kind of
basic question but I'm really curious
about the answer what was your biggest
takeaway of writing 100 million offers
and also 100 million leads the offer is
a strategic question that influences all
aspects of the business and is also a
mental exercise that people can feel
like they're making progress on their
offer a lot faster leads is a lot more
about activity and implementation and so
people can get ideas from like the lead
magnet chapter but then you have to
start reaching out to people posting
content or running ads to start start
getting leads in the door right and so
there's a little bit bigger of a hurdle
with leads than there is offers but it's
also the the main driver of business is
letting people know about your stuff and
so I think that many people will
mentally masturbate to the idea of
making these amazing offers but I think
formal people make money by actually
letting people know about their stuff
which is leads what went through went
through your mind when when you rewrote
it for theth or 19th time so unless I
can work once and have something provide
value on an ongoing basis which is a
high leverage activity um then it makes
no sense I think most people shouldn't
write books because the amount of work
it takes to make a great book that
actually lasts the T of time is
extremely difficult I think I I uh read
a blog post where they said uh how to
write a blogbuster blog post and there
was a chart where they said if you put
in like 100 hours to write only one blog
post there maybe will be a million views
but if you put like 50 hours there maybe
will be just 10,000 views it's exactly
that there's diminish in marginal return
but an increase an exponential increase
in absolute returns you know the gold
the gold medal Sprinter in the Olympics
versus the silver medalist like from a
business context the person who's at the
gold medalist might have worked 10 times
more right to get this much more out but
what's the difference in absolute of
gold versus silver everything just being
this much better people are like well I
don't want to work 50 more hours to be
this much better but being this much
better might make you the best at that
whatever the blog post is or that
business or that solution and the amount
of winner takes all the economy has
shifted towards people want the lowest
risk solution and so if you have the
best solution then it is the lowest risk
thing to buy and so to be number one
versus number two 80% of the economics
sometimes 90% of the economics go to
number one and so it makes absolute
sense to work 10 times harder even
though you might only be this much
better from a marginal perspective on
the chart of rankings that might might
make you 10 times higher some context we
have like a book summary application
where we give also exercises and tips to
implement the book what's your average
take on on books and uh I mean book
summaries is it good did you use them
before I don't read many book summaries
uh mostly because you rely on the person
who's doing the summarizing to find what
they think is the most valuable thing
for you right because a lot of times
what I find if I read a book The the
Nuggets that I find are not the main
Concepts it's actually the details if
you don't know anything about topic then
summaries are great to give you a latus
work a framework to understand the rest
of the information that you're can
consume but once you have a basic
understanding it's in the edges which is
where you can expand your knowledge
right and so there's there's not a lot
of shortcuts to getting really good at
something now a bit of selfish question
but I'm really curious about your
thinking yeah yeah okay so you remember
you had a video where you scaled a no
strip business to 50 million in six
minutes could you do this with a book
summary app basically do a breakdown of
a book sum so it's an application yeah
it's a it's a subscription based
application yeah got it what's the price
point uh $10 okay what's what's turn I
think 15 to 20% monthly or yearly
monthly monthly got it um so you have to
fix that first at the end of the day
everything's going to be ca LTV so like
if there was one single metric that I'm
going to look at a business it's CA LTV
ratio so how much it cost me to get
somebody and how much do I make from
them over the lifetime until that metric
is better than the competition so like
blinkist right I think that's a one
that's like that I would have to look at
there TV and what are the things that
they're doing that like why am I why are
going people going to come to me versus
them right so either I have to be more
niche in my selection of books so that
I'll have a wider selection for a
narrower audience like competing against
Amazon is very tough but if you if you
if you Niche down into a specific topic
then you can actually have a wider
selection because blink is is just going
to take the the best sellers right for
every every category because that's
going to be the the most people and
they're VC backed and they're funded and
they can acquire customers at a loss for
a long period of time acquire market
share and unless that's the game you're
trying to play then you have to play it
different which is I want to I want to
be really specific about the Avatar that
I want to go after and so that's where
you do a little bit of research ahead of
time and say okay is there an
underserved Market that might actually a
have a big reading preference so like
salespeople is one of the most common
professions on planet Earth from a
personality perspective how many sales
guys read all the time I don't know I
would have to I would have to look into
that and so you might be like okay well
sales guys aren't the guy but maybe HR
Specialists read a ton okay well if they
read a ton and there's like blinkist
might have one book on HR but I could
put a hundred different things that are
related to that or one degree separated
and then I can create the illusion of a
wider selection of topics but around a
narrower a narrower Avatar or concept
right I would start there and then over
time you can expand if you if you want
to and just reach you know you go
adjacent you go to finance or you go to
whatever like this is me just
spitballing again like I did the no
strip thing from the the economics
perspective you have to get LTV to the
point where like your turn should be
under 3% in order to make this really
work once it's under 3% monthly yeah
monthly monthly I mean ideally you want
to maintain 80% annually at least if you
want this thing to be a big thing all of
my attention would be only focused on
that like until you fix that there's no
point in acquiring customers cuz they're
just going to fall out the back end like
there's literally no point cuz then
you're also getting lots of people in
that will then say that that thing sucks
you know what I mean I'm not saying it
sucks but I'm just saying like they're
they're a friend of theirs is going to
say hey I signed up for this thing
they're going to be like oh I tried I
didn't like it and then they're like oh
okay maybe I won't I won't stick on it I
want to be so quiet about what I'm
building until all my metrics are right
and then I want to blow the the doors
off but most people want to keep hitting
these income goals rather than looking
at the the metrics of the business that
are actually going to drive the
long-term goal cuz like anyone can
Market their way to 100,000 or a million
a month even with an app like this if
you blow enough money enough people find
out about you can do it but then you can
only maintain it as long as you're
spending that much money the moment you
your your spend drops your income drops
and that's not a business that I want to
be a part of our uh USB is that we are
doing we are we are in Hungary and we
are doing it in Hungarian and there is
no other application in Hung okay that's
great if we scale to maybe Poland we
would do it in Polish and not in English
and that's a USP I like that and I mean
then at that point I would just look at
I I try to model as closely as I
possibly can the number one player in
the US from a ux perspective from the
selection of titles all that kind of
stuff and then I would and I would see
if my metrics change if I do that if not
then it's like there's some assumption
that I'm basing this business off of
that's not right in the Danny Miranda
podcast I think you talked about skills
versus skills could you expand this
maybe uh a meta skill is a skill that
helps you acquire more skills learning
how to read is a meta skill like learn
like learning how to learn is a meta
scale at at the with the broadest brush
stroke all the way chunked up learning
to learn well quickly and retain
information and be able to implement it
is is a skill you give a 100 people a
course right that's free the difference
between the people who are going to be
successful and not successful are the
ones who already have sufficient meta
skills to be able to then use the
information and implement it like at at
one polar extreme you've got somebody
who's completely incompetent right who
like you have to teach them how to turn
on a computer and On The Other Extreme I
can say go build me a company and the
person can do it so this person can
translate a directive into each of the
sub buckets and knows how to do that and
so it's really like your success
percentage basically is predetermined by
how low you break down the skill
requirements for someone to be
successful so like the reason that I
write the Books at the grade level that
I do isn't so that people who are
experts don't get value from it so that
it makes it even easier for experts and
it makes it attainable for people who
don't know so I can get 70% of people
who read the book to get leads versus
10% of people to get leads if I just cut
out some of the steps and made
assumptions about their skill level the
last 10 or 20% the people who are
experts are still going to benefit from
I'm just also going to include turn on
your computer here's how you do that and
from the software perspective with what
you're doing that's also how you get a
way larger percentage of your clients to
activate typically we make assumptions
because we assume that every customer is
just like us and so they have the same
meta skills as us and they have the same
interpretation or perception of the
world and the ux and so that that
assumption isn't true like all you have
to do is and I'm sure you've done this
like you look at people scrolling on
your app and you see the heat maps and
you're like why are they clicking that
button because they have different
skills and experiences that they're
bringing to the table and so then we
just continue to accommodate it break it
down to the level that you could show it
to a three-year-old and they would
immediately know how to use it like the
fact that babies learn how to use iPods
is an indication of how how simple they
have made it to humans to use and that's
why they have such Mass adoption how
would you teach someone how to learn we
already know how to learn it's just that
most people don't know how to teach
everybody learns stuff all the time
right if I if you touch a stove and it's
hot and it's and it and it burns you you
learn not to do it again like learning
is is natural like we all learn but
people who want to teach a specific
behavior don't know how to do it and so
it really just comes down to three
things which is what do I reward what do
I punish and what do I extinguish right
so reward is you give a carrot right
after someone does something punishes
you you know you zap them or you smack
them after they do something or
extinguishes you do nothing right so if
your wife walks in and she got her her
nails painted neon orange and you don't
like it you might not want to punish her
because that's probably going to have
negative ramifications in the rest of
your life but you might extinguish it so
you might not say anything about the
nails or you might say something
different she's like do you like my
nails I might say something back like
I'm I'm happy that you got what you want
what we're doing is what Behavior are we
training and so if you think about learn
teaching as training I think it's a much
more useful word to think through
because at the end of the day you have
only taught someone if their behavior
changes in the same context as in if I
want you to say these words when the
phone rings if I say cool we're going to
put you through this training and then
the phone rings and then you don't say
the words you have not learned and I
have not taught you and so it's how many
times can I simulate this experience the
stimulus the context so that I can have
them do the behavior I want
within the context that's going to
trigger it and then reward them
immediately and that's how you have a
feedback loop that trains people to do
something so that is why the streaks in
the application and the gamification and
those stuff how would you restructure
the education system if you could H yeah
sorry for dis no you're good you're good
I would focus almost exclusively on meta
skills teaching people how to learn step
one and then teaching people the things
that are the next level underneath which
is learning how to write learning how to
read learning how to speak learning how
to do math like those are the those are
the building blocks of everything else
that follows and in the school of the
school of Alex or the school of hosi
everyone passes only when you learn
there are only 100% and you continue to
do it until you learn I like the
arbitrary division of grades along age
is ridiculous to me and I think if there
were a lot more clarity around the goal
which is like until you can read 10
pages out loud without making a mistake
you do not move on if you can do that in
a day fantastic if you can if it takes
you a year okay I don't judge you on
that it's just how long will it take you
to learn the skill so a good buddy of
mine Dr cashy taught an autistic kid how
to read he couldn't stay still reading
uh for more than one word at a time and
then he would like have fits or whatever
and so he came to train the child on how
to read with a bag of Skittles and so
when the kid would read a word he would
give them a Skittle when he would read
more words in a row than he ever had
like a record he would give him two
Skittles so he rewarded the behavior and
then he had big bonus rewards when he
would ACH unlock a new level and so he
kept doing that and within one afternoon
he had him reading a full page what is
the behavior that I want to reward how
can I reward more of it now none of it
was punishing he didn't smack him when
he messed up when he read less he still
gave him one to reward him for the
activity and then when he read more he'
gave him extra reward as the kid becomes
less fool on Skittles and he's like you
know sugar he like doesn't want any
Skittles anymore the Skittles become a
proxy for approval and they work just
the same how do you know that when to
when to punish when to reward or when to
extinguish we try very hard to almost
exclusively reward because punishment
changes Behavior faster reward changes
Behavior Behavior longer it just takes
longer to work right like if if someone
you know calls me Alex and I don't like
that and I slap them and I say never
call me that again I might change their
behavior really quickly if I leave the
room and someone else says walks in they
might say I was talking to Alex because
I'm not there to punish them and so
punishment only works as long as the the
source of punishment is there and the
person doesn't get accustomed to the
punishment because punishment itself
becomes desensitized over time and so to
effectively punish someone if you want
to consistently punish then you have to
increase the intensity and variety of
punishment over time because otherwise
people get desensitized to it if you're
always mean and yell at all of your
employees eventually they stop carrying
so you have to increase the level of
your threats right you then have to say
I'm going to fire you I'm going to kill
you right you have to make these threats
increase because you create the you
increase the intensity and the variety
of how you claim to punish them reward
you can reward long enough that you can
then extend the gaps between reward to
eventually you don't need a reward
anymore and people will continue to do
the activity because they have always
done it so it's the exact uh example
with Dr cashi and the guy yeah I would
imagine if he was doing this over and
over again he proved the point I don't
he's not like a full-time reading
teacher the concept is that he would
read and then maybe the next time he
comes in he gives him a Skittle every
other time he
reads and the next time be every third
time and the next time it be only when
he when he hits a new record if I can
get the kid to read long enough that he
actually starts to like the story then
the story starts rewarding it of itself
and then I can move away and then the
kid reads without me and so
fundamentally that's what you try to do
when you train any activity is that most
people who are experts at anything get
rewarded from the activity itself
because once you develop a level of
Mastery in the skill you enjoy it
because you're good at it so we hope I
hope we will meet again and maybe speak
longer thank you very much dude I
appreciate you Kristoff thank you so
much thank you for inviting your
community and hopefully your community
got value from the event um and
hopefully they use the books and and
grow the economy and hungry and uh and
all get you know way way better at
whatever it is they're doing you are
incredibly committed to education and
self-improvement how do you select what
you will pursue for Education there's so
many possible topics uh so what process
do you go through to select uh what
you're going to be educating yourself on
and how do you also select potentially
someone to educate you on that topic we
do everything off the theory constraints
at acis.com which is basically that a
system will grow until it's constrainted
until it's limit so it's kind of like
the idea of the the weakest link right
so it's it's finding what the weakest
link in the chain is or the constraint
of the system is so that we can DEC
constraint it and then grow to the next
natural constraint it's a very
simplistic look but it's extremely
effective because it just cuts down all
the noise into like if I had to pick one
thing that is the big limitation of this
business what would it be and so then we
just get laser laser focused on solving
that one problem solve that problem and
then we move on to the next constraint
and if we solve that problem and the
business doesn't grow then we pick the
wrong constraint and so sometimes the
constraint is your ability to judge what
the constraint is which is why you know
wisdom is one of the hardest things to
earn which comes from experience right
is that you're able to you know
recognize patterns um and so for me
right now uh to enter the the other part
of the question I'm focused on um
learning about brand stuff right now so
brand is my big topic that I've been
diving really deep on brand and media
and I'll probably write a book on brand
just from the findings that I have
because I don't think there's many good
books on brand cuz you can I could read
you 20
definitions of brand and branding and
they all sound like cockman and so
coming up with an operationalized
version of what that means so that it
can actually be useful and I I I try to
learn the stuff so that I can use it and
then whatever I learn I just you know
pass it Forward because branding for me
despite being now quote known for this
or like an organic content guy I've only
been doing this two years like this is
brand new to me like I you know I have
way more experience on the paid outside
that's what I did the last decade and I
you know people got to see a tiny taste
of that when I was launching the book
but that's that's the big thing is
finding out what the constraint of the
business is and if you need to chunk all
the way up it's if you want to grow a
business you have to sell more clients
or make them worth more or decrease risk
those are the those are the things that
are going to grow the value of a company
and so just simply asking the question
like why do we not have 10 times more
customers or why are we not making 10
times more money and then figuring out
what the answer to that question is
often times is the constraint just
because you're saying hey I'm I'm
currently educating myself on on
branding and that's fresh for you what
would you say is like a maj takeaway in
terms of education for the topic of
branding that you're just like I wish I
would have maybe known this when I
started to try to learn about this two
years ago this is like a Pandora's Box
if I start talking about it it might be
like 10 minutes so I I can I can rip on
it but like Buckle in the audience so if
we look at the origins of what a brand
is right where do Brands come from Brand
comes when you brand cattle right that
was the original use of a brand and so
why would you brand cattle because you
want to change change the behavior of
people who look at the cattle so if you
have a cattle that doesn't have a brand
and the cattle that does the people who
are looking at it will behave
differently if the cat the cow doesn't
have a brand I might take the cow for
myself or I might kill it or I might eat
it I might do whatever but if the cow
has a brand on it and I know the guy I
might return the cow to him right so it
changes what I do all right that's an
important point so the point of a brand
is to change or elicit a desired
behavior in the widest percentage of
your target audience all right now how
do you do that you do that by making
associations between something they
don't know your brand in the beginning
with something that they do know that is
positive and rewarding if that's what
you want right and so the index it's a
4x4 uh box of what brand really is you
have the uh the the direction so you've
got away from and towards and then
you've got strength so very high and
very low so you know if you have a
really weak thing that's away from it's
like I kind of don't like this thing you
know slow Wi-Fi you know like whatever
like bad brand on the flip side you
might have a political party which
depending on on the audience might be
super strong and away from or towards
now Taylor Swift for example would be
someone that I would say has a very
strong brand and towards there's not a
lot of people who really hate Taylor
Swift um and a lot of people who really
love Taylor Swift right so it's positive
and it's strong right somebody like Ray
Romano if you heard that you know or
like Tim Allen from the old sitcom days
might be someone who is positive but
weak a lot of people know who he is am I
going to show up to his event probably
not the idea is that in order to build a
brand we simply pair things that people
know with things that they don't know
the things they don't know is our logo
our tagline our company with things that
they do know and think are positive if
you were to think about the brand as a
bouquet of
flowers it's like having many flowers in
a bouquet and so if I were to break the
bouquet and spread all the flowers there
is no bouquet but simply by gathering
them together by making associations I
create something new and that bundle of
associations is the brand now if I were
to break one of the flowers or make it
rotten it would affect the appearance of
the entire brand and so that's why if
you make a single mistake a Dylan mulany
move for Bud Light you can affect the
entire brand if I get a DUI or somebody
you know gets you know accused of doing
some sort of terrible heinous act right
it affects the entire brand R Kelly bad
brand now right despite all the positive
the one broken rose or the one rotten
flower affects the entire bouquet we
have to be very deliberate about what
associations we want to make with our
own brand so that can continue to
positively associate ourselves and the
point of the brand is that we get a
desired action or behavior from a
specific audience the idea of growing
the brand a lot of times is that you
sacrifice some audience for other
audiences so like when I was starting
making content I did it in my closet
right and there were some hardcore
people in the OG mosy media days that
are like I appreciate you that were like
man I miss the closet videos right now I
might have lost some of those people
when we started making a little bit more
polished videos Etc some people not all
of them right I traded some I traded
losing some audience to gain more when
you making a brand move you're basically
always making a bet that you will gain
more of your desired audience than you
lose by making a change and so you can
approximate or slowly move a brand over
time by making more associations in One
Direction and fewer associations in the
other and so that's how you can move a
brand over time Bud Light made a wrong
bet they thought and maybe this is just
a corporate group think right that if
they made an association d m that they
were going to get more people to buy
their beer that was I mean fundamentally
that's the only reason you would do it
as a company right you believe that
long-term you're get more people to buy
your beer the problem was that wasn't
true now the interesting thing is that
there probably are people who were a big
fan of that move it's just that there
were more people who weren't they were
far away right there were more people
who were not a fan of that move and so
that became an away from Association and
so that is what I am trying to
encapsulate and put together um into how
to brand
uh because now that I feel like I
understand it a little bit I see it as
in my opinion you know it's kind of like
Neo in The Matrix when he's talking to
Morpheus and he says so you telling me
that I can dodge bullets Morpheus says
well when you're ready you won't have to
and so we learn all these tactics about
sales and marketing and show up rates
and cro hacks and all this [__] but if
you have a brand if you see the Matrix
everyone shows up to your calls no one
has price objections everyone is excited
and refers their friends it just takes
longer to make associations because
fundamentally all branding is is
teaching you were teaching someone to do
something you want them to behave a
certain way and you have this red red
card and when you see red it means stop
that's all we're doing so green lights
have strong associ strong Brands they're
positive everyone loves green lights
right like it's a simple thing just no
one owns it but green lights are a great
positive Association it's a great brand
right and so that's that's the idea of
what I'm what I'm kind of diving more
into and I see it as the ultimate cheat
code for business it just takes a long
time to do and most people aren't
patient you're telling me I can dodge
business problems I'm telling you that
once you have a brand they become
irrelevant you talk about deleting
problems as your favorite way of solving
them yesh how do you decide what's
deletable versus what's not because I
can imagine the uh the person who really
loves that strategy doing nothing and
just deleting all problem so how do you
prioritize a problem worth solving
versus a problem that is deletable well
it's just percentage likelihood of
impact chunking all the way up to like
will this cost me number of sales like
sales velocity will this decrease the
lifetime value of customers and will
this increase or decrease the likel that
this that whatever I'm doing right now
continues to occur so we're trying to
value a company right we look at what's
the sales velocity how many customers
they sell what's the lifetime value of
every customer because then you can
extrapolate what their run rate's going
to be at at scale at Max unless we
change something and then you divide
that by risk which is How likely is it
that there's going to be an outside
event that's going to change this thing
from continuing to occur this box of
making money How likely is that they
will it will continue to grow or at
least stay the same and so if I have a
problem I have to be able to track it
back to one of those three things and if
it doesn't really track one of those
three things or there's another problem
that has a much higher likelihood impact
in terms of it's higher likely and it
has a greater effect size then I'm going
to prioritize that it's just that often
times if someone's like man I really
think we should change the colors on the
site I would just say like what's the
likelihood like I have been notorious
for having ugly as [__] sites my entire
career and you can make branding make
associations and I think there's there's
an argument there but what's the
likelihood that it's going to affect how
many companies do deal with us it hasn't
up to this point and so is it a
constraint of the business no is it
something that I could improve
absolutely there's also a hundred other
things I could improve I could also send
more emails which I don't do like
there's lots of things I could do but
what are the few things or the one thing
that matters most which then Lads back
up to what is the constraint of the
business if I look at the highest pric
competitor in my market and I one up
them and then they one up me potentially
like is there ever a point in which we
just say like we're priced premium
enough or do we always have to go for
the top like how do you make the
determination of Premium there's
basically four positions in the market
you have luxury all the way at the top
which is technically a VIN good which
basic which means uh when I increase the
price demand goes up and that's because
there's an association with the price
that makes it more valuable so the fact
that everyone knows how expensive it is
affects the value that I get that I get
from it the fact that everyone knows the
Rolex is 100 Grand the one that I'm
wearing whatever then I actually M it
makes the Rolex more valuable so it
becomes a virtuous cycle which is why
lvmh is one of the most valuable
companies in the world then you have
premium which is basically the above
average so it's there you have to pair
utility with the premium in luxury the
pre the the extra price tag is the value
where whereas with premium like BMW is
premium they're not luxury they're a
little bit better at a lot of stuff and
so you pay a premium because it is a
little bit they use better materials it
breaks less whatever right and so then
you have your you know your mid your
your run-of-the-mill your commoditized
space which sucks and then you have your
lowcost leaders which they make their
entire business on how can I drive uh
efficiencies and operations at all
levels of the business so that I can be
the lowest priced uh person in the
marketplace right and still make a
profit to to route to your question of
like when is enough enough the key
indicator for me and most of this like
the the quote higher ticket world you're
not luxury goods the fact that it's
expensive is not the reason that people
want to buy it right it's so it's
actually technically a premium I'm more
extreme about the price to Value
discrepancy than anything else and a lot
of people get into trouble because they
raise the price so much that it is it's
just an excess of the value they provide
and so then they actually create a
negative experience like if Chipotle
were $50 people would probably not not
like Chipotle even though the product is
really good but at $50 I don't know and
so the reason Chipotle is so viral you
know what I mean is like the price Dev
value discrepancy is so good that they
tell their friends right and so that's
where this kind of marriage of how can I
just shortcircuit people's brains from
value perspective which is what I what I
try to do with the books and the courses
so that it becomes viral on its own and
then my cost dual car customers is zero
and so then everything after that is
just gravy are the four variables when
you're using this you've got the price
the value at the top which is what they
get right the price is what they pay
you've got your cost of goods to deliver
and then you have your profit left over
and so it's playing with those four
variables so that you can maximize the
the amount of absolute profit that the
company makes pricing High has become
shorthand and where I think people get a
lot of benefit from the offers book is
that when you price higher you
automatically weed out shitty customers
and I think many times that is the real
reason that a lot of people's businesses
grow from that price now obviously
there's more profit there's you have
access things that you can that you can
deliver on um but a lot of people don't
actually take that excess money to
create a better experience they do a
gotcha and then they never get anything
from that customer again and so that's
the wrong way to use it but if I had to
think like okay what are the reasons
that you know a company might be
successful that does charge premium is
that they actually reinvest the the the
premium price into a superior product
and they are very clear about the Avatar
that they go after and what the
quantitative requirements are that are
black and white that they know from
looking at their best customers their
top 20 top 5% of customers and then
saying we're only going to cater to
these customers in the future because
the likely that we can give them a great
outcome is higher and then that can
create you know you can Merit or earn
the premium that you have because you
have data that supports that if you are
this type of person we can get you this
type of result what does the ideal
experience with an accounting firm look
like to you and I asked because one of
the things that stuck with me um is you
said you've never done your own books
like you've always considered that
something that was delegatable important
to delegate you've also referenced
bringing I believe accountants inhouse
kind of going back and forth between
Outsource and in-house so what does that
ideal relationship look like to you now
and maybe what did that ideal
relationship look like when you were
going through your first you know seven
figure and eight fig company a lot of
Professional Services should look at why
for inspiration you're like what does
that even mean you don't you don't want
to like clap when the Wi-Fi is working
you just notice when it doesn't and so
you just want it to be in the background
you just want it to work right so a lot
of companies are like that like there's
a lot of services that people think they
need to like over you know communicate
stuff on like I just want the financials
to be accurate and I want them to be
timely that's it and I want things
broken down in a way that allows me to
make business decisions and that's where
like I think the the the top tier of
accountants transform into fractional
CFO and CFO kind of materials where they
actually help you use this data to make
informed decisions about the business is
there a way that I can translate what we
do into how it would affect a business
owner's life so I'll tell you a little
story because I think this might be
really Rel this will be really relevant
for you guys so one of our portfolio
companies um has had a ton of growth
three years they went from one location
to I think we're at 38 locations now
right all self-funded off cash flow all
right so really really tremendous growth
uh in 3 years years and it's compounding
so it's growing faster and faster and
when we were at about 30 locations we
were stuck at 30 locations for like two
quarters and so I got on the phone with
the CEO and he was like dude I just I
just feel like I don't know how many
locations I can open based on cash flow
and cuz they had net receivables were a
little bit extended things like that
right I I like shook the screen for
because it was Zoom call um I was like I
need you to freeze frame this feeling
you have right now I was like okay I was
like think about this feeling feeling
you have I was like what you are feeling
is finance as the constraint of your
business you do not have a finance
function that is operationalized enough
like you do not like you are
underdeveloped in the finance function
you have a bookkeeper who's not that
good as soon as he like I could see it
just clicked I was like that is the
constraint of the business until we get
the finance function in you're going to
just be operating blind and then once
you know we have this much cash flow we
can open two locations a month or three
locations a month then you can be more
aggressive with everything else because
you're confident that you're not
bankrupting the company accidentally on
your own if I were an accounting firm I
would try and pinpoint the problems and
relate them to how it's going to affect
growth in the business like how is the
constraint so that you can talk in the
language that a business owner is going
to understand like they just how many
I'll bet you like if I could see
everyone's hands how many people in your
audience all the business owner does is
go to the right go to the bottom and say
so we made more money this
month great and so I think adding that
level of strategy of like like by the
way I think this is a little fat
compared to other companies that we're
looking at this is a little bit under
compared to other companies we're
looking at and this might be an area of
opportunity little things like that that
actually add value to the business if I
were somebody who is in charge of
account I'd like to get this answer in
less than 60 seconds because I have I
know we got to go and I want to be
respectful of your time this has been
incredibly informative how much of a
skill should you develop or how much
would you educate yourself before hiring
for it so for example like do I need to
be a sales manager before hiring for
Sales Management what you what you hit
at is one of the hardest parts of
business you need to make an informed
decision without context which is why
being an entrepreneur you end up
becoming a jack of all trades so that
you can have enough context to make at
least an informed decision and so I'm
going to steal a playbook out of oops
wrong shoulder there we go out of lela's
book here and I'll give you my tactic
around this which is you want to
interview for people who are sales
managers and you don't want to hire
anyone for a little bit which sounds
tough but what you want to do is you
basically want to interview for
information now if you meet a a a gold
star that's amazing but you want to talk
to people and if you know more about it
than they
do they should be teaching you and once
you talk to 10 20 people they're
basically like expert interviews for
what it should look like and so then you
get a very good idea of what the role
should look like after listening to
people and you'll get an understanding
of the level of nuance and I'll give you
this one little tidbit that is super
powerful F when it comes to judging
skill the quality and quantity of data
that someone chooses to collect around
their particular department is almost
directly proportional to their skill and
so for example I have lots of marketers
who are like I'm an amaz my product's
amazing and I say cool tell me your
metrics are I like what's time to Value
right what are the key activation points
like what's churn right like just some
of these metrics and they're like well
dude our refund rate's really low right
but I'm like okay I was like well what
about the marketing side they're like
well cpms are this this is our
clickthrough rates this is our you know
this is our conversion on the page this
is our percentage the schedule this is
our percentage the show this is a
percentage open rate this is percentage
click like they go through all this
stuff and I'm like right so I can see
very clearly that you're a better
marketer than you are at product and so
simply getting an idea of the quality
and quantity of the data that someone
collects around their Department we get
like when we hired our director of
people it was the first time that I had
someone actually tell me metrics I'd
never heard of and I was like she's the
lady she's the gal loves you and that's
how we are here and I literally got like
150 questions I had to narrow it down to
five or six it was so hard you mentioned
something in the100 million offer that
to hit your first 100K you don't need a
lot you just need an offer to sell and
that's exactly what we did uh but right
now we are hitting a bottleneck and our
biggest bottleneck is operations and you
know I want to know how exactly you got
out of gym launch operation because we
have a very similar business model for I
know service providers for what what
service providers mostly agencies and
digital Consultants with lead generation
and sales the way we do it is with a
one-on-one Consulting and in a group
coaching format so coaching models in
general tend to be very difficult to
scale because the reason people come to
you is for expertise in order to get
other people to provide that expertise
then you have to create lots of experts
who then eventually walk off and start
the business on your behalf and take
your customers with them I would say
like there's a couple different
approaches so the first is that there's
the law firm and the McKenzie kind of
consult model there's a a track to
become a partner in the business and
then that's kind of the whole business
structure so there's a a way to share in
the profits they do make lots of money
but the owners of those end up having to
Lo delute themselves out not that
there's anything wrong with that you can
make lots of money doing it but that is
that is a a version of the model the
other way is to productize the basically
get narrower on the solution that you're
providing and productize it to the
greatest degree possible so that anyone
could do it even if they have no
knowledge of it in terms of like the
implementation of the thing that is more
the direction that we went
uh with gym lach cuz we had a very
specific we don't even we didn't even
work with all gyms just to show how
narrow we were with it we worked with
only micro gym owners we have now
expanded to health clubs as well the
five or six years that I was doing it
before we sold we were only micro gims
and so just to show like how incredibly
narrow that was someone had to have at
least 30 members assigned lease one
employee and be running this type of
model for them to be a customer and then
if they fit all those things we could
generate a lot of Revenue using our
playbooks I could have somebody who had
no gym industry no expert whatsoever and
still say send this email say these
words here's 10 recordings of people
doing this exact same thing this is the
expected value and so that's like from
the delivery perspective now operating
the business overall comes from talent
and being able to find people who are
just as smarter smarter than you and
people say that but like when you
actually meet somebody who's smarter
than you and then they admire an aspect
of what you've done so that they start
to work for you that's where you really
start to have the magic happen What are
some of the things that agency owner
should avoid doing if they ever want to
scale any your experience okay so what
thing should an agency owner avoid when
they're trying to scale yep yep I mean
the same things that any business owner
would want to avoid when they're scaling
agencies tend to fall into the you know
they they tend to fall into the bucket
of trying to be everything to everyone
so maintaining the discipline to be very
focused at the problem that you're
solving and who you're solving it for
and I think that solves 90% of the
problems from a strategic perspective
for any small business owner including
an agency the second piece is that if
you're in a service based business the
quality of your Talent is going to be
directly proportional to your growth
because you're you're basically selling
people fractionalized people that's what
service businesses are right you're
selling some level of training that
you're able to give and having more
efficiency than an individual business
owner would have like the the classic
you know small business owner Leen
agency that charges $2,000 a month the
idea is that if they were to hire
somebody full-time to run these ads it
would cost them5 or $6,000 a month but
you have copywriters designers and media
buyers and P designers who all work a
fraction of their time for this one
business and they can get it more
efficiently and you can still do it at
good margins right like that's
fundamentally what service businesses
are and so the quality of that talent
and the culture that you have at the
business to attract and keep that Talent
um are the kind of the key or The
crucial pieces of the success of the
model you mentioned something in the
book where you mentioned the agency
model where you hire an agency to learn
the stuff and you internalize it and
then when you have stopped learning you
replace an agency but me teaching agency
models agency businesses how to become
irreplaceable in your perspective how
should one go there should we start with
one business then upsell the next and
upsell the next and upsell the next
offer creating the irresistible offer
isn't necessarily about having a zillion
products it's more about explaining and
communicating the many small things that
you have to do anyways and so rather
than saying like I'm going to generate
leads for you that's like one outcome
but there's many things that have to
happen along the way you have to create
landing pages you have to write copy you
have to you have to have followup
sequences you have to work work the
leads you have to have scheduling you
have to you know you have to split test
you have to make new creative like
there's lots of things that have to
happen in order to just get the single
result and it's just making sure that
we're delineating those things because
an unbeknownst or an ignorant uh
business owner I said ignorant in the
technical sense like they just don't
know um would have no idea what you're
doing you're like yeah just go get me
leads it's like well it's much easier
said than done and if I was doing it
from an outbound perspective might be
like well I have to warm up domains I
have to you know spin up different
accounts I have to split test different
email openers I have to like you have to
explain all the steps and they're like
wow there's a lot more work that goes
into this now I can I can appropriately
value this price tag that you've ascribe
to whatever the service is so that's
piece one in order to be Irreplaceable
often times you'd have to go after
significantly bigger customers if you're
an agency for Fortune 1000 for Fortune
500 companies it would be so costly for
them to spin up at scale the level of
talent that's required to do like
programmatic media buys across 100
different Platforms in different
countries and then the likelihood that
they want to leave or do this on their
own is significantly lower the idea that
any service provider is going to become
come truly Irreplaceable like any
business can do anything on their own
and I would prefer to put myself out of
business and do it in a way that aligns
my customers with me than have a model
that I know is is basically has a timer
for obsolescence not everybody works
with Fortune 500 companies right
sometimes you many people uh they might
work with you know small and medium
businesses they help them let's say you
become a marketing agency for
chiropractors in New York and you become
so good at that in general people won't
leave you because you're just good at
that particular service and the thing is
small business owners are really tough
because they're the problem like they're
super erratic they're super volatile
their cash flow is Lumpy they don't know
where their next paycheck is going to
come from and to no fault of your own
they can cancel because they just can't
make payroll that month look at the
biggest agencies that exist ogal V you
have Vayner you know's up there now who
do they service massive companies why
because the quality of the customers are
higher and so they know that when they
sign a contract they actually stick with
the contract we all know that if you
have a small business owner who signs a
12-month agreement for agency Services
he's good for 3 months the biggest model
that I've seen for for small business
owners from a marketing perspective um
was an agency that was running $300 a
month $300 a month price point because
they had figured out and like there's a
key here is that like those business
owners are so price sensitive it's not
whether you can sell them it's whether
you can keep them on their worst month
the price isn't based on the value that
you can deliver on the best month but
how much you can keep on the worst month
because that's where the churn comes in
the best model that I saw uh was doing
SEO for small business owners and they
had completely automated every aspect of
it um it was basically Just A playbook
and I think it generated reviews and
maybe a couple phone calls a month but
at a $300 month price point if they got
one or two phone calls a month it was
worth it so the bar to get over to to
ascribe value and especially on
something that I call like a nuisance
business where it's like I know I should
be maintaining my reputation I know I
should be doing some of this stuff okay
for $200 or $300 a month I don't feel
guilty about not doing it because this
is being handled you're in a Consulting
model right what happens is some clients
actually do the work and they get
results and some clients they need a lot
of follow-ups and they need a lot of
accountability from you how do you
maintain that like I know I'm getting
very nitty-gritty into this but D I'm
I'm good with NY gry you talk to
basically one of the core problems of
all B2B businesses which is that you end
up taking over the person's entire
business until eventually they're like
yeah if you could just send me a check
every month and you do you run the
business that would be awesome that's
why being very disciplined about problem
definition from the services that you
provide number one and here's the one
that everyone messes up who you pick
it's not like even if you work with
chiropractors right as that as that
example you don't necessarily even want
to work with all chiropractors you look
at the customers that you have right now
that are the best customers like the top
20% or the top 10% you say okay what
characteristics do these people have
that other people don't have in my
client list and that's both from the
soft pers the hard perspective what are
the quantitative differences they have a
certain size business they're over a
certain amount of month they have a
number of locations they have a certain
amount of employees number of customers
like you just get all that data on them
and then also what was the experience
that they went through when working with
me and was it different than some of my
other customers because one of the the
things that happens often times is that
the first few customers you get become
really sticky and then you start scaling
and then you have this front revolving
door but you still have your core
business of these people that you had in
the beginning right so why is that
because these people got more help from
you and actually got delivered more
value and then you basically tried to
scale without scaling the value that you
delivered to the original customers
right and so if you're at whatever
15,000 a month and you've got five
customers and they're all like having a
great experience and you keep signing
people on they keep leaving it's like
okay well instead of me trying to sell
five this month why don't I just sell
one and do a great job and then not lose
them and like that's the key to
compounding in a service business once
you pay down the IGN Bas pay down the
inefficiencies of them not knowing what
to do yet and being very specific about
who you serve and who you don't like we
didn't work with personal trainers
cycling Studios and like yoga studios
100% could use our model we didn't work
with them because the founders tended to
be psychologically different their
adherence was super low because they
just come from a totally different
worldview than the guys who are more
Fitness weight loss transformation
focused even though at the end of the
day it's just a membership with a back
room where people work out but mindset
wise they had a very hard time um kind
of adopting a different model even
though monetarily it totally made sense
which means you need to have discipline
to say no dude this is so hard to say no
to this new upcoming business because
you know it can help them but they just
don't fit your criteria 100% dude I have
13 companies I get 1,800 a day who reach
out who right so you have to say no it
feels weird to like say no because a lot
the I get so we specifically that's why
most people stay poor they can't say no
and what happens is you go for the
short-term money and you sacrifice the
long-term money because then you just
get in this operational Rat Race and
then you scale up your your costs to
meet the fact that you took on all these
customers that you shouldn't have taken
on to begin with and then you have to
pay them every single month so then you
have to keep on taking on customers that
you shouldn't have taken on to begin
with and you get in this vicious cycle
that you can't get out of until you
downsize you take two steps back five
steps back fix your ego and then say I'm
only working with these customers
because ethically I know that these are
the ones that I have the highest likely
to success with everyone else I have
mediocre success and I can say it's
their fault I can say it's my fault it
doesn't really matter all that I know is
that the likel that they achieve what I
think they should achieve is low period
so I'm not going to sell them aren't you
afraid that the T will go smaller like
of course you can build a niche an inch
inch wide and a mile deep there's 30
million small businesses you don't need
to service them you like there's there's
50,000 gyms that fit the model that we
have now if you want to build A10
billion company then yeah you're going
to have to go after a bigger problem but
if you want to build a 9 fig company you
can that in almost any industry so you
mentioned that when you started out you
started with the first five customer
framework that was awesome and then you
just grew with referrals so this
question came from a fitness consultant
herself and she said that with the
competition that the fitness Market is
how do you stand out honestly it's just
being authentic 99% of the fitness
Market just looks at what other
influencers doing and say I'll just I'll
copy that and I'll do stuff like that
but then you just do a worse version of
what somebody's already doing zooming
all the way out fitness like there's no
secret work out more stop eating shitty
you'll look better over a longer time
Horizon like that's what it is right
there's going to be a subset of an
audience that is like you genuinely and
they want to get their they could get
Fitness information from Alex but if I'm
a you know a 45-year-old Indian mother
I'm probably not going to be her source
for Fitness information even if I see
the identical stuff as another
45-year-old uh Indian mother now if that
45-year-old Indian mother looks at my
fitness content and tries to make
content like mine it's going to seem
weird you can stick out by actually
being yourself I know it sounds trite
but the real like this is real there's
so many unique aspects of someone's life
and the things they're interested in
compared to other people that if you
just lean into those differences there
those unique as the things that you're
actually into that are weird right
Rogan's into aliens and mushrooms and
comedy and fighting who would have told
him like you should be Joe Rogan and
you're going to have people who like
some aspects and then the super fans
will be people who overlap on two or
three of the interests that you have if
you picked my brand it be like dessert
working out philosophy Business
Marketing sales they're different
they're people who follow me because
they only like the business money stuff
there people who follow me because they
only like the philosophy stuff there
people who follow me because they just
think the desserts and calav stuff is
funny like it just depends on what
someone's going to come in for but if
you're just you then you can stick with
it for the long term and that's what's
going to build over time and make you
quote stand out because there is only
one version of you that's lived your
life so just live it publicly thanks a
lot man I think we are at the end of our
10 year thank you very much for being uh
here and keep writing great books I hope
I hope you make so much money from the
book um and just and crush it because at
the end of the day there's more problems
than anyone person can solve and I hope
we build businesses to solve them so
explain to me how the franchise works
yeah so we have a lot of clients that
want to work with us and we have a lot
of closers that want to work with us and
Yan and I we just can't manage
everything ourselves it's just too many
people we had two options option number
one is Place managers to replace us
right and then give like two to three
accounts client accounts to each manager
so they can manage them obviously and we
can scale that way the problem with that
was that managers only get paid so much
and they only care so much about the
business itself right but when it comes
to Partners they get 50% cut they get
exactly what we are getting 50/50 the
franchise thing is interesting because I
feel like you would be able to achieve
that simply with a profit share rather
than getting investment and equity and
all like the because if if speed is the
goal then you can basically do the
makeshift in terms because like they're
I'm assuming many of them aren't
planning on selling right and so the
only reason the equity would be valuable
is if they're going to sell it sometime
in the future and buying quote more
locations isn't really a thing either I
would imagine that just like it'd be a
lot faster to just contract you know
basically put put legal language around
getting a profit share in the structure
you know the cut that you have like many
companies have scaled sales orgs you
know what I mean like Insurance
brokerages are just massive sales orgs
like real estate agents are massive
sales orgs and so um they don't
necessarily have Equity you know what I
mean Equity deals cuz those can just get
litigious and there's lawyers years and
it just T I'm sure you guys have already
seen this like it just takes more time
and I feel like there might be like you
could probably remove a couple of the
components to get the same behavior
which is ultimately what you're trying
to do is get people who act like owners
so that's just that's me just shooting
right off the cuff of just looking at it
so that's kind of why we kind of came up
with the franchise model to put like a
nice barrier there so it's for people
who like have the experience in the
space of running an agency or like
scaling managing High ticket sales teams
but now you're getting like the
infrastructure that we've kind of built
over the past four years I mean you
could still do all that without the
without the franchise agreement but what
problem are you solving why are you not
bigger it's a management problem just in
general with bringing on more partners
and doing it faster and doing it more in
a more organized way so what you said it
does make sense because that would
remove some friction and it would allow
us to bring more people without risking
you know the the equity in any way I
mean based on the model you have you
guys can Own 100% of the you know like
the franchise or but even if you if it
was just like you know the the main Co
you can still have stream because you
have the software so tracking becomes
the issue but since you already have
that infrastructure built the ability to
just make sure that they get overrides
now if you want to put you know a
$10,000 Buy in or something just because
you feel like that increases commitment
levels I mean that's fine um but if you
look at like a Chick-fil-A for example
are you familiar with their their model
yeah right and so that you know each
location probably cost I actually don't
know the buildout cost but I would
imagine it costs at least a million
probably one and a half to build a
location for Chick-fil-A and The
Operators put $10,000 in and so it's
more of a symbolic gesture than it is
like them actually you know contributing
Capital to whatever the thing is but
they actually don't own equity in the
business so they get a 50/50 profit
share after a royalty that goes to
holdco just looking at what they've been
able to build it seems that that that
structure works without the equity um in
in terms of eliciting the behavior that
you guys are going for but from
everything that you said even right at
the beginning you were like well uh we
needed something that was more scalable
because obviously we had lots of people
there's many people who have scaled
businesses with lots of people and so it
sounds like it's actually a talent defic
defit like you need to hire somebody uh
or bring someone who's a high level
operator who has scaled a sales-driven
org what's what's Revenue right now uh
revenue for the phone sales organization
sure well every month is different
around like four million right now per
month is that gmv so like gross gross
sales volume and then you're getting
whatever 20 25% on that yeah so you'd be
looking at a at somebody who's scaled a
sales work from you know 10 million to
100 million and who's really Ops heavy
so you'd want somebody who looks like
who's very uh very leadership driven not
a systems person wrong that's not the
right person you're looking for somebody
who's who you admire take this away I
mean it you need an adult right it
doesn't that's not a function of age
just saying you need someone who has
experience doing this uh because if I
were looking at like if I were going to
go buy in right to phone sales the first
thing I would do is hire an operator
because right now all the things that
you've described have been people issues
so if I'm operating on the theory of
constraint which is what we do I would
say okay well then people issues seem to
be the main problem for this business so
I'm going to hire somebody who has
experience in this particular domain in
a sales or who has gone from X to Z
million dooll question where do you find
such people well you guys are sales guys
right so it's outbound outbound is the
easiest thing to do uh you could also
run ads but the best people already have
jobs uh and I mean you guys know this
from from your business right and so it
would be it would be Outreach Outreach
is the is the easiest thing to do go to
LinkedIn and Linkedin has so many tools
now like search for people who meet
these you know these three or four job
titles um probably like a an a senior
vice president or V you know a VP of
sales uh sales director might be a
little too low but probably a VP of
sales uh or VP of sales Ops something
like that uh like you'll have to play
with the title it is kind of like an ad
in advertising like you have to play to
figure out when you get the right
avatars on the phone uh but as soon as
you get it to click then you're like
okay these are the types of people I
want and then you talk to as many as you
can and the limit tests that I have for
highle town is that I should be learning
from them on the phone call so if I feel
like I have to teach them stuff they're
not the right person like if they're
teaching me things which is also great
because then you can keep taking notes
and after 20 or 30 phone calls you're
like okay I have a very good idea of
what excellent looks like and I can make
a more educated decision on the type of
person that I want but that person who's
very operational should be a people-
driven leader especially in this type of
workg for the second part of this call
um we would like to just bring our
partners too and uh just ask some sales
question in general and learn from you
you know with our model do you believe
that we should utilize groups selling
methods like webinars seminars events
that way we can compress the time frame
we make money or just focus on one toone
sales I think it depends on on the
product that's being sold usually
products above
$30,000 and that's why we're focusing on
like one to one model right now I think
you can do so the way that I like
building uh sales orgs is having
repeated sales materials and then
individualized so like repeated sales
materials are going to be like the vsls
the webinars things like that but you're
not you're not closing on those webinars
you're just qualifying in setting and so
I want say sales guys to be doing as
little information spewing as humanly
possible and really being able to start
the call with so you ready to buy and
then yes or no and then work your way so
you have 60 Minutes to close rather than
okay great now like Discovery like let
me talk to you about how we might be
able to help you because if you because
then sales guys get really tired of
saying the exact same pitch then they
sound like robots then they get zoned
out because they're saying something
they're not listening and so the talk
ratios get way off um and so I prefer
having as much of the standardized
information share sharing being done
before the call so that the closer time
can be maximized to closing rather than
just sh like teaching but I wouldn't be
trying to pitch 30k stuff directly to a
payment page I'd probably be pitching
that to you know qualifier set calls
yeah that's how we're uh we're doing it
right now but we've seen some other
people they have like live webinars you
know and they have the sales guys on the
live webinars and even though they're
selling super high ticket offers they
try to like do that communication SL
information SE of the call like just
through the chat chat and then once they
show a level of Interest then they get
them on the call well they're using the
webinar as the set correct at the end of
the day there's a certain amount of
information that someone needs to have
or certain amount of like exposure that
they have to have to a brand or a
product for them to you know make a
buying decision and so that can be a
long set and then a short close it can
be a set webinar close it can be a long
webinar then a close like there's just a
certain amount of selling you know the
runway for the plane has to be a certain
length doesn't really matter where you
slice it it just has like this is amount
that the majority of people need to have
for making a purchasing decision now
some people might need less and that's
okay cuz they probably got it beforehand
from other things that they've consumed
so if you want to say okay how do I sell
why I want to increase the likelihood
that some that the the highest
percentage of people buy then I want to
create an experience that the highest
percentage people get all of the
information that they need prior to the
closing conversation and so if you do a
webinar as a big set thing I mean to me
that's the same I mean that's all the
same like if you run ads to webinar ads
to vssl then they go to auler or you
know if you have a live call team where
you have a number that becomes the CTA
and then the call teams answering calls
in real time operationally I wouldn't I
wouldn't upend my entire business
because of just a slightly different way
of doing it because I I think it's more
happy to Glad um as long as your
throughput is good and you're you know
like you're making money and you're
growing right now I would I don't know
if that would be the constraint of the
business so like I think the stuff that
we were talking about earlier like that
seems more of the constraint than kind
of the the the individual tactics you
know in in the example you gave what
show method for building trust and
credibility on a sales cool um in like
the fastest way possible like what
method what approach do you often take
for that well I mean brand matters more
than anything uh like right off the bat
and the the you know the the vast
majority of like the the hard closing
tactics and hard sales tactics have to
exist in lie of not having a brand right
it's like we have to make up all this
hard stuff uh it's kind of like in The
Matrix when he's like uh when you're
good enough you won't have to dodge
bullets or like you saying I can dodge
bullets it's like well when you're ready
you won't have to so like the brand is
when you're ready you won't have to but
if you don't have that which is the big
thing that you should have but if you
don't have that then it's the same
things that you would normally do you're
going to try and find common ground be
relatable uh trying like a lot of it
just comes down to how well do you
understand the Avatar right so I think a
lot of sales teams under under prepare
by under understanding the Avatar the
Prospect and over educate on the product
like if I understand what a 45-year-old
woman's suffering from I can basically
do the same sales call and at the end of
the call say I can pitch therapy I can
pitch I can pitch weight loss I can
pitch a gym membership I could pitch you
know I could pick cleaning services it
doesn't really matter because if I
understand the Avatar really well I'll
be able to speak to her pains and what
you said is true like brand is extremely
powerful and with the clients that we
take on for our agency do you recommend
that we go for people of very strong
Brands and take that approach like
that's that should always be the Focus
right like always go for the brand and
from there yeah strong brand strong
product for sure fair question though
yeah relatability Common Ground what's
been the number one reason you seen show
up rates increase or decrease uh it's
it's 100 gold b's no silver bullets so
when we when we go into a company we
have a something called a lead nurture
checklist and so it's just like 17
things that we do and each one of them
adds like 2 to 5% and so that's how we
can get something from like 30 40% show
rates to 85% show rates it's just doing
a lot of little things so I I would not
look for like the one trick it's just
like okay how quickly are we responding
how how much information do we provide
them beforehand are we providing a
personalized video like can we give them
a gift card for showing up that they can
share a coffee with us like just how
many different things can we add in to
increase the likelihood that they show
can we can we create an open loop
between the set and the close that
they're going to get information that
they are they had got their their their
interest peak is there a way that we can
say that we're going to show them that
we're going to do a certain amount of
work on their behalf then we're going to
give them the deliverable on the next
call right so they have a huge incentive
they have huge curiosity so that they
would want to show up like this is
particularly true an insurance product
so like we have an insurance company and
so like we create personalized insurance
plans it's like okay well how do we get
more people to show up but we don't want
to send them the insurance plan that
we're going to make them before the call
we just say we'll explain it to you on
the call yeah we Implement a lot of
those tactics as well probably there's
some stuff that you're doing that we
currently don't have at the moment as
well I don't know if it makes sense to
share on this call but you said those
kind of like 17 things is aul you can
maybe like send it to us no so um oh no
man all right honestly it really depends
on what the business is if we're looking
at an insurance business versus a weight
loss business like it's more applying a
principle across but that being said the
big one that's that's probably missing
like it's usually the big obvious thing
which is we can always do the hundreds
of little tax itics but you're trying to
dodge bullets rather than like winning
before you start which is like why why
do so few people trust you like that's
the big that's the big like I see the
Matrix and then everything else becomes
irrelevant so for acquisition. comom our
show rate on calls is nearly 100% so if
we call some if we say hey we'd like to
find out more about your business today
is Tuesday our next opening is Thursday
of next week so 9 days from now show
rate still 100% because of brand we
actually don't need to do any of those
tactics now we have those tactics so
that we can help the the companies that
don't have those level of Brands but
like you want to Stack the deck you want
to answer the question why does no one
trust me and solve that otherwise you're
always going to deal with these issues
like do the fundamentals for sure but
the big the big things that'll matter
most is who you're choosing as your
customers so Vista you guys heard of
Vista private Equity so they're the
biggest they're the biggest software
private Equity they've got a gazillion
dollars whatever the way that they look
at a business is that they do a customer
analysis and so they look for the 8020
right they look for the 20% of customers
that are worth more than everyone else
and they then do a customer analysis and
say what do these 20% have that the
other 80% don't and then they
exclusively look for customers that are
that 20% and then they say no to
everyone else and so then what happens
is if the sales velocity remains
unchange they 5x the business so
sometimes you'll make more money just by
saying no so you can have the capacity
to say yes to the few guys that matter
more and if you're not getting more of
those people then solving that problem
rather than saying like how do I keep
getting how do I how do I polish a turd
instead of going from that perspective
just saying like maybe I just should not
try to polish turds because it's still a
turd right and like how do I get the
people who are much better companies to
be attracted to my business and if you
have a customer list that people aspire
to be like then you'll get more and more
people like that's where that's like
kind of The Branding side for you guys
which is how can I associate with better
quality Brands so that other better
quality Brands realize that what we do
is legit you can try and optimize the
[__] out of something but like usually
it's the big obvious stuff and we don't
look at the big obvious stuff because
they're actually harder problems to
solve and they take longer but it's
where the most value is unlocked what's
the ideal frequency and the topics of
coaching calls that would increase the
overall performance of Setters and
closers so I would say it's less about
the topics of the calls and more about
what you're training repeatedly and what
you're rewarding so sales is one of
those really interesting businesses or
like you know departments that you can
see very clearly like you guys have
probably seen different sales teams and
they have very different cultures and so
it'd be like what are the cultures that
create the highest performance in our
experience you know you can go on all on
either extreme you can have a very
punishment driven culture which is very
individualistic or you can have a very
team driven culture which is typically
reward-based what you want to reward is
adherence to the script not closing like
that's a huge shift for most sales teams
if you reward adherance to the script
then what happens is you get everyone to
follow the script now if they aren't
closing then you need to change the
script but it's much easier to change
the script once you've taught adherence
than it is to have a bunch of Lone
wolves who do anything they can to close
the deal which then impacts your brand
so like a really simple you know tactic
we did at one of our chains was we just
said cool we'll give them five bucks if
they follow the script whether they
close the now mind you that the tickets
are smaller right it's just higher
higher volume we'll give them five bucks
if they follow the script and if they
close or they don't close they get paid
either way you know what's interesting
the thing they're most curious about
when they send their managers is do I
get the five bucks for the adherence
even though they make three times more
on the close so we still we still give
them benefits for closing but they want
to know whether they got the approval of
the manager because the $5 actually
matters less than the approval from the
manager saying you did a good job the $5
is more of a token that makes a lot of
sense and if you can imagine cuz
everybody here is sold before if you got
on a call and you knew that you could
get paid no matter what just for
following the process it takes some of
the pressure off like think about like
you hop in the car like I'm just going
to make sure that I get my bone no
matter what on on the adherence but
guess what happens when everybody hears
to the script you [__] close more
there you go because sales is one of the
biggest issues where you have false
positives where someone goes Rogue and
then closes and basically gets
reinforced for doing the wrong thing and
then they start doing the thing that
they did that one time that worked and
then it doesn't work over and over again
so they Chang their behavior they learn
the wrong thing right and so then you
have to course correct right that's why
sales like it's all about adherence and
then then we can be really strategic
about really making sure the script is
beautiful and crisp and concise uh and
we just and we just drill the team on
adherence the big topic I want to
address is how to sell emerging Tech you
don't sell emerging Tech you it's it's
selling the plain flight versus the
vacation if I could tell you that your
financials would be absolutely accurate
and updated in real time would you want
that how how much would you be willing
to pay compared to what you currently
pay a lot more great what if I said I
could do it for less than what you're
currently paying are you interested
great this is what I need the fact that
I'm using AI is irrelevant you just sell
the outcome and then you not really no
one cares AI is great for YouTube
clickbait but for for sales it's
irrelevant that was like one of the main
wanted to get across what else you want
to do for the next
16 you must be getting a ton of
businesses didn't you some a lot of AI
businesses that are coming across your
disc right now at acquisition. comom
what are the things that's making that
sort of jumping out at you and what are
the of commonalities between things that
make you really go oh wow that that
seems to have some kind of staying power
uh the vast majority of AI businesses
that I look at are are dog [__] and so
they're either they're not real AI which
is 99% of them they're basically just
built on chaty PT which is fine there's
nothing wrong with that but I'm just
like let's not claim that we're creating
AGI on the other hand it's it's people
who' have no business Acumen and so
they're like it's totally different like
the the normal laws of business don't
apply it's like they have always applied
and they will always apply because
they're just how business works right
those are the the the vast majority of
people that I see in that I do think
that AI implementation for Main Street
is an enormous opportunity so aiying if
you will and I I don't think I think
your first conclusion is Right which is
being the custom guy is tough you know I
mean it's just it's it's all things to
all people which is nothing to no one if
I'm talking to the audience now if you
guys want to get into this world what
you want to do is look at an industry or
an avatar that you understand well and
so one of the things that like why
combinator and some of these great like
you know legendary investors look at is
how much time a Founder has suffered and
lived through a problem I can talk about
breathing cuz I've had two nose
surgeries I've been falling asleep on my
hand since I was in eth grade so that I
could breathe so like I've lived with
the problem for a long time and I've
tried many different types of solutions
so I have tons of Industry knowledge if
I were to start a company like that if
you have a job right now or have had any
type of job you've worked in a business
that's a great Baseline of background
knowledge that's difficult to just jump
like even if you were a server at a
restaurant for 2 years you still will
probably know more about restaurants
than 99% of people who aren't in the
restaurant industry like I don't know
anything about how restaurants work cuz
I've just never really worked in one you
could probably be aware of because you
now also have this understanding of what
AI can do to think okay there's a
hundred problems in a restaurant is
there one very specific problem that I
can solve well and is very similar
between restaurants CU as soon as you
get the point A to point B you can
create the clear value prop and you can
message around that getting extremely
specific which is I think what you were
saying that you give the advice to is
super smart and it makes the problem set
really narrow to solve so you can become
an expert that's a an inch wide and a
mile deep the exact same thing the
reason that most people don't do that
when they're starting out is because you
don't have enough demand you have so few
leads that come to you that you're like
why I mean [__] I need to pay rent this
month and I only got four leads this
month and all four are completely
different but I need the money and so I
get it redeploy that cash into getting
really concentrated on your marketing
which is what offers and leads is all
about so that that you can find that
specific Avatar that you can over and
over again repeat which is also why
referrals are so strong because if you
do a good job they will send you other
people just like them the the question
is is yes I can pick a niche to do this
AI automation I can build AI Solutions
and a sort of targeted one but what is
the opportunity that I should Target
within the niche and that comes down to
either a as you said industry experience
that you already have or sort of B what
we've said is finding some sort of
partner within the industry so we say
you can either try to pay them for the
time as a consultant or you can just
message enough people and say hey look
I'm looking to bring these kind of
solutions to the industry would you be
willing on working working on this with
me I need a little bit of your specific
knowledge but in exchange I'll create
this thing and you can refer you can
basically have first STS on sharing it
to your network and you can make some
money that way so yeah I definitely
wouldn't do it as a Consulting
relationship the the thing that you're
going to be selling is the product and
so having a consultant who's the one
who's in charge of the primary value
that you're driving is not a good idea
and so you'd want somebody who's
long-term incentivized to continually
improve the product continue to innovate
the product see the things that are
coming around the corner to keep it up
to date make it better make it stronger
Etc it really just comes down to how to
have a normal Business Partnership so
all the normal rules of business apply
and this person has some specific
knowledge you don't have and you should
ideally have specific knowledge they
don't have they should be asking the
question like why do I partner with the
people in your community if I'm an AI
developer right if you're trying to
figure out which of the problems to
solve in an industry it's just value
created times ease of implementation
that's the equation which if you chunk
it up it's number of potential customers
times gross profit per customer if I
have six different problems I could
potentially solve which one has way more
people who have it which one's easier to
do which one unlocks the most value one
thing that we starting to see as as us
ourselves actually run and build one of
these these AI automation agencies now
ai development company as well is that
by building a a development team that is
capable what is is your take and your
experience with how important that
development resource is I mean it's sure
the event you must know working with
developers can be a complete plan but
having them inhouse and having a really
good team to rely on as you shoot for
those big opportunities can be key what
what's your experience being like this
and how important do you think that
development resources when you're going
for those bigger
plays
very okay I mean we were thinking the
same thing so I was glad to know you
agree on that it's the product like if
you're in a service business the quality
of the people that you Ed to provide the
service is the product and so those
people usually want to be compensated
well because if they are really good
then the places that they're coming from
will want to pay more to keep them and
so you have to give them a great place
to work and a financial incentive or
some upside that they get exposed to
that they wouldn't otherwise like you
want them to feel like owners and the
best way to do that is for them to
actually be owners if you're trying to
get on The Cutting Edge of Technology
then actually having the people who are
good at that is the business well it is
a great resource to have a really killer
marketing team under your belt but the
the development side of things I I tend
to find at least in our experience has
been a harder thing for us to to create
it's hard you don't know it like it's
easier for you to do the marketing stuff
because you're good at it so you know if
someone's full of [__] on the interview
you just don't know if anyone's full of
[__] on the interview because you have
no context the most important hire which
is why I say this is you need a
technical co-founder you need somebody
who has a real stake in making sure that
the people are coming in are actually
good not that you're checking a box and
saying hey I have 14 people on my
development team anybody in the in the
true high-tech world knows that one
amazing developer is more valuable than
100 B developers this is the hardest
part of business is hiring people who
are really good at something without
knowing the in-depth knowledge and
that's where like leveraging somebody
who might not want to work for you that
do think is brilliant to at least
interview or double check on how good
they are um is really valuable that's
where like building a network becomes
important and getting even some tests
like of aptitude for them to take so
that you can at least get some sort of
Baseline but it's all going to be about
how skilled that person is cuz ideally
if they were as good as you are at
marketing then you guys would probably
have a really successful business we've
been fortunate enough to to find that
find that magical sort of technical
co-founder so um we're starting to get
him really well comp both getting inity
as well so we are off to the RAC and
that's completely changed our business I
can't even stress for for anyone of you
in here that that key hire is just a
complete G I'm sure you've had it Alex
in your businesses where you've just
found that right person and it just
completely changes things all right
appreciate you guys thank you and
appreciate the community thank you guys
for showing up hopefully the book serves
you guys well how do you feel like in
general do you think like the you think
you brought as much value as you
promised I hope so I try to answer the
questions to the best of my ability and
provide value to the a so